and new information tonight on the
discovery of a man found dead inside the
trunk of a car earlier this month the
coroner identifies him as amir [ __ ]
police were tipped off about a bmw left
at a complex near tropican in valley
view with a bad odor coming from it
victoria saha joining us from that
complex with the very latest on the
investigation
i spent some time trying to talk to
neighbors about amir [ __ ] no one seemed
to know who he was and they didn't
believe he lived there but they did tell
me that bmw that was parked was not
there for too long on friday august 19
police responded to the budget suites
after a suspicious car was parked
officers say they immediately smelled a
bad odor coming from a white bmw
and as they went to search the car that
is when they found amir hagi the clark
county coroner reports his death as a
gunshot wound to the head ruling it as a
homicide nearly 10 days after the
discovery residents say they still have
questions as to where this car came from
night before
i took some trash out and i did smell an
odor
and i thought well there was a trash
but apparently it wasn't i saw all the
police out here all the police cars and
there was a lot no one of the employees
here
got pretty sick
she'd walked by
and
it was that bad scent several residents
told me that they did see a tow truck in
the parking lot dropping off the bmw
before the body was discovered however
they could not provide me the name of
that towing company the coroner could
not provide amir haji's age or where he
came from but i did find a 41 year old
amir [ __ ] reported missing from phoenix
arizona from back in june i did reach
out to the missing person unit as well
as the phoenix police department to see
if these two cases were related but i am
still waiting to hear back victoria saha
8 news now
victoria thank you and victoria also
reached out to metro police to see if
they can provide any more details on the
case they did not have an update on that
investigation